it's beautifully produced written acted  by wonderful and tim matheson who i've  known for for 40 something years we play  opposite one another and  we have a great time um  and yeah we're gonna do another season  soon they've they've announced it so i  can say it netflix is very want you to  be very careful what's the show it's  called virgin river virgin river and  where can they find it netflix on  netflix yeah how do you like working for  netflix they're great really they're  great they they have writer first  refusal on everything i do so anytime i  want to do anything even a play i have  to go you have to ask them and ask them  but they're great they've never said no  you can't the only thing i think they  would not want me to do is is  like a another mini-series